I have to start with the most important
question and it's directed right at you
did you watch the game of Thrones finale
and what did you think green oven off
clean the nut and that's all she thought
I follow her around in the hallway going
Queen all she has today its Sun she she
loves it
I really love it we didn't know thank
you
did you where did you end up watching
the episode that's not last night here
because I was in Moscow on a junket so I
couldn't watch the finale so I literally
I was like no one look at me don't I
didn't want to turn my phone on like I
just
and of course you know I so yeah I
watched last night um yeah I have so
many more follow ups because I loved the
video that you guys did and I saw that I
think the world saw I think she is a bit
sick of me with my fan theories about
[Music]
but I would I'd like to you know what I
will say this Anya Anya alright Arya and
Sansa are my favorite arcs of the series
I have a lot to say I also agree I loved
loved and I loved the very end of the
episode without getting into anything
specific you know and anyway we could go
off on a tangent but uh I have a whole
bunch of fun questions but at least I
think they're fun so here we go let's do
it let's do it we'll find out what how
fun they are this is you can throw
someone else under the bus do you have a
favorite person to work with and why
this is not that serious now we don't
see each other let's see what happens
should we be say we should we say we
can't say Joe yeah let's say we can't
answer each other cuz I would say
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what neck hole is always really
fun to work with in the beasts in the
costume no he's not that fun when he's
in the costume because he you know he
can't do anything he can't eat he can't
do anything so he's a bit grumpy but out
of costume and in his Hank gear he's
he's really funny he plays a lot of
games on set he's quite the troublemaker
so is anyone that I remember mortis Oh
ever no no this let's all say self and
she'll say cold what props or costumes
have you taken home from set you can
mention this movie or a previous film or
show or whatever what have you borrowed
oh I always ask I don't steal yeah but I
basically say oh just you know I'm gonna
take this mmm and they go oh I like to
call it liberating the process i
liberated this from set right and what
did you liberate know much recently and
liberated nothing from this but I took a
corset from Game of Thrones it's funny
very similar I the last thing i
liberated was my push-up bra from
Molly's game oh I also took my shot bras
I mean I'll never wear it was but I'll
never wear it it was crazy cuz that
movie it was crazy
and I was like out of anything that I
would that I have to represent Molly
bloom I'm gonna take this that's amazing
love that woman the last time you pulled
a prank on set
oh very recently yeah this movie this
maybe and what can you share what it was
yes we James is having James was in a
bit of a grump
he was in a bit of a grump one day and
so he decided though Jess and I decided
that he needed cheering up and so he was
on wires for this scene and we decided
that we wanted to have the Macarena
play on the sound system and the stunt
guys would kind of puppeteer him
as a surprise it was a good I'll say
this
he was never grumpy again he wasn't he
wasn't on his lesson on his lesson um do
you remember your first movie or TV show
crush first ever yeah oh I mean I liked
John Cena I wish you could have seen her
reaction that was your first what from
my [ __ ] cuz my brothers used to watch
Ross wrestling yeah it's a TV show right
yeah wrestling no so I used to sit there
and watch em below and then I sat next
time on a plane and it was uncomfortable
because you know he's so jacks and that
was just like I didn't like him anymore
after that he was jacked because he I
didn't have much seat oh I didn't say
anything to him I was too sorry mine
would have been I was obsessed with
Corey Haim oh no yes Corey Haim but I
think my very first was Joey McIntyre
from the new kids on the block and I
made a bet with my sister that I was
going to marry him I better $1000 did
you did you did you really pay huh good
for you no I didn't know I understand I
lost it's okay yeah yeah movie that
you've seen that thing's my last
question already what movie have you
seen the most Wizard of Oz I think I've
seen true romance the most oh my god
that's like so random but so not you
really don't
I love true Romans what today great felt
so grateful you've seen that a lot the
most out of any other film think so
either that or Titanic that makes it I
have to go listen uh congrats thanks so
much for the question thank you